here are all the memories in tears of
the Kingdom in order as you can imagine
giant spoiler warning for massive story
beats in the game make sure to subscribe
to Gamespot for More Tears of the
Kingdom coverage
it is good to see you
Princess Zelda of Hyrule
and Link
Keeper of the master sword
your blade has been fully restored
go on then link draw it once more
great Deku Tree thank you so much
there is no need for thanks I merely
watched over its renewal
[Music]
amazing that a sword can heal itself no
matter how badly damaged it becomes
it can do more than heal
the sword will continue to gain strength
if bathed in sacred power the stronger
that power the more powerful the sword
becomes
the potential of this Fable blade May
well be Limitless truly the work of a
goddess the sword that grows ever
stronger
[Music]
Master Sword
what is that
[Music]
ah
a
foreign
cannot save you from me
filter
you carries that fragile sword a link
placed his faith in you
and that was all you could do
oh do you know our names
[Music]
foreign
oh
where am I
we didn't mean to startle you I'm sorry
it's okay my name is Sonia
and could we ask what your name is
I I am the daughter of King Rome of
Hyrule Zelda
an unexpected answer
we are the king and queen who founded
Hyrule after all
or at least we were the last time I
checked you two founded Hyrule and
you're the king
[Music]
um my name is raru king raru of Hyrule
king raru and queen Sonia
well that must mean
[Music]
as I thought
this is not the world I know
time so far back in the past it's become
Legend
so it's true this is really the era of
hyrule's founding
your presence here is just as strange to
us Zelda
but if you like Sonia have a secret
Stone and are able to manipulate time
then your story makes sense
[Music]
oh I believed her right away you needed
the secret Stone as proof raru
I can feel your light power within her
as well as my time power
additionally I sense that we share a
blood connection
oh
I see
in any case Zelda
you had said that you needed to return
to your error as soon as you possibly
could
yes
in my time something terrible is
happening
[Music]
I need to get back there but how do I do
that
I don't even know how I got here in the
first place
[Music]
now Zelda dear
oh you don't need to solve your problems
all at once why not come back with us to
the castle
no I
will tell everyone that you're a distant
relative of ours
[Music]
it is true after all
we'll get you fresh clothes too
I'm sure an answer will come to you
wisdom takes time
I don't know what to say
hmm I wonder
mineral
she may have some idea of how to get you
back to your era
minaroo you said
yes she knows far more than anyone about
our people
and like us my older sister has a secret
Stone
we'll call on her
foreign
it is quite an interesting device
this is definitely not from this era
that said I believe there may be a way
to get the travel functionality working
here
I'd like to Tinker with it a bit would
it be okay if I borrow it
yes whatever you need
I really appreciate your help then I'll
hold on to it
thank you
so you really believe my story
that I came from the future
I never doubted you for a moment
mineral
do you know of a way we could help to
return Zelda back to her time
I suspect it was the power of your
secrets stone that allowed to travel
through time
to put it simply secret Stones amplify
the power their owners possess
I am able to separate my spirit from my
body
raru can repel or destroy evil with his
power of light
and Sonia she can control time
[Music]
as for you I can sense both light and
time powers
but your secret Stone seems to amplify
your time power
ultimately the secret Stone only
amplifies your power
it doesn't suddenly Grant you Mastery
and control that's still up to you
that means if you don't already know how
to get yourself home
[Music]
there are stories about the secret
stones and a forbidden act called
draconification
to swallow a secret stone is to become
an immortal Dragon one blessed with
eternal life
oh
interesting another way to reach the
future though not a very quick one
so you think these stories could hint at
a solution to our dilemma
yes
but there is still more to those Tales
to become an immortal dragon is to lose
oneself
that is why it is forbidden
I thought maybe this could lead to a
solution some way to transcend time
but if you have to sacrifice your heart
and mind sacrifice what makes you you
I'm sorry
I wish I could help more
back where we started
there's still hope I think the answer
the answer to this problem lies in study
and learning more about the nature of
your power
sure Sonia would be happy to help you
okay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
will bow down before me
approaching our position it's more than
we thought
it's a swarm
there's so many of them
but why would they
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
that blast wiped out all the little duga
how is that possible
laughs
so brute force will not be enough
[Music]
a secret Stone of the sonai
how interesting
allow me to offer you my deepest
apologies
on behalf of the Gerudo
for taking so long to accept your
repeated invitations
it is our desire to be accepted into the
protective Embrace of your kingdom
to serve it Faithfully
a welcome appeal Ganondorf
I will accept your vow of fealty to the
kingdom of Hyrule
I understand that a single male is born
to the Gerudo every 100 years
receiving such an appeal from you
a hero to his people and a king by birth
well it is truly reassuring
it is my honor
when your zonai ancestors first
descended upon these lands long long ago
they must have seemed to be gods
and now you rule as king and have taken
a high rulian woman as your wife
your emergency has certainly risen above
your admirable lineage
most impressive
[Music]
it is unfortunate that the noble zonai
no longer graced this world with their
presence
all except you and your sister that is
even if something were to happen to me
both my kingdom and the peace it brings
these will endure for generations to
come
your actions today are appreciated
Ganondorf I look forward to your future
endeavors you may leave
your majesty
[Music]
King Rory
I believe that man's heart holds many
dark ambitions
just his name
even that
gives me pause
I am well aware of his evil nature
for that reason and others I want him
close it will be easier to keep an eye
on him
there is nothing to worry about
oh
you well
you seem a bit distracted
I apologize
keep getting lost in my thoughts
thinking about how I can return home
power over time
if I were able to learn that kind of
control I might be one step closer to my
era
the secret
is to think of it like drawing out the
object's memory
you ask the object where it was how it
arrived where it is now and then you
coax it back to that original Moment In
Time
the object's memory
I'm sure it will become almost like
second nature and you will be able to
find your way home but Zelda there is
more on your mind than just that
you of course do want to get back to
your time
but you also desperately want to help us
out in this era am I close to the truth
how did you know
I do not believe it is possible to keep
anything secret from Sonia
oh your concern is very sweet Zelda
but listen you can focus your attention
on returning home
after all you possess more than power
over time
you have a sacred power that can dispel
evil
both of these Powers will help you
protect your own era
Queen Sonia
and of course you must make it home safe
to put Link's mind at ease
link
that is not a name I have heard
Royal Knight
been originally appointed for my
protection
he'd be saving both me and Hyrule from a
great evil
oh a hero is he he is so very dedicated
and he refuses to back down from any
challenge
ah
he is very strong
and his heart is good and true
ah I can see that you have absolute
faith in him hearing you speak so highly
of Link
I find myself wanting to meet him as
well
indeed
yeah I would also like to meet him he
must be quite the brave courageous
Knight
what a picture Zelda papers of him
[Music]
all right Zelda we are alone as you
requested
what was it you wanted to discuss with
me in private
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my I'm surprised to hear you say such
a thing
that is quite out of character for the
Zelda I know but then you are a puppet
of Ganondorf
did you really think we hadn't realized
your deceit
thank you
foreign
[Laughter]
finally it is mine
[Applause]
[Music]
energy
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
as for her she is merely the first
victim of your arrogance
you tried to control
and you will die knowing that you've
failed
[Music]
princess
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hahaha
all right surprise my spirits
[Music]
eliminate this heat of matter animals
please no survivors
we just received word that the Lost free
Village in the gerudu desert Has Fallen
at this rate the Demon King's Army will
overwhelm us
stand
our only hope is for me to defeat the
demon king
raru
Demon King
someone you can
but you are not alone
you have the Gerudo Goron Zora and Rito
leaders as well as Zelda
and of course
You Can Count On Me
[Music]
there's something I'd like to show you
all
[Music]
right
secret stones
hmm
stand with me
I need all your Aid
[Music]
foreign
before you face The Demon King tomorrow
there is something I must tell you
I came I came to this era
after finding a man Underground
hmm
go on
when I witnessed what the secret Stone
did to Ganondorf at that moment I know
for sure
what we found underground that was him
still alive still powerful
he continues to live on all the way
until my time
in tomorrow's battle
we won't be able to defeat him
no matter how strong we think we are
he'll survive
[Music]
and you
maybe so but it is my duty to try
[Music]
it was my hubris that set us on this
path
tone from my error in judgment
and above all else
I remain the king of Hyrule
as with any leader it is my duty to
safeguard and protect my people
even if I must risk my life
and if it proves impossible for us to
defeat Ganondorf
we rely on your night and that legendary
sword he carries
our last line of defense will be link
[Music]
but remember that was a future where you
never appeared in this world
you are here now
Zelda
I believe there is a reason you were
sent to us
it has to mean something
[Music]
the reason I am here
long ago my people known as the zonai
came down from the Heavens to the
surface of the world it was said they
were descendants of Gods
they bore Treasures from these same Gods
secret Stones capable of amplifying the
abilities of those who possessed them
using the knowledge of the zonai my
younger brother raru became a great
leader he met a young woman named Sonia
and they would wed
rauru gifted Sonia one of the secret
stones
together they sought to establish their
Kingdom
this is how the kingdom of Hyrule with
rauru and Sonia as its first king and
queen came to be
the future looked bright
however tragedy suddenly struck
a man of great evil emerged from the
desert
the leader of the Gerudo Ganondorf
killed Queen Sonia and stole her secret
Stone
using the secret Stone Ganondorf
transformed into the Demon King
he then created swarms of monsters and
attacked
Hyrule rose up to face these threats but
the evil power driving the monster's
forward was staggering The Defenders
were on the brink of defeat
raru then came up with a plan to turn
the tide of the war
he entrusted secret stones to warriors
with exceptional abilities they became
sages and United in an effort to finally
defeat the demon king
rauru and the sages outnumbered the
demon king and should have been able to
stop him
however
the Demon King's power had grown far
beyond anything we could have imagined
[Music]
stand his strength
our friend appeared old but lost
[Music]
foreign
he committed himself to one final Act
[Music]
that Pride will be your downfall
Ganondorf
foreign
[Music]
solve your problems
that I could read it to pay the price
for this don't be so smug
I know exactly what it will cost me
thousands of years
you're wrong years from now someone will
appear with the sword that seals the
darkness
a swordsman with the power to defeat you
link remember this name
[Music]
thank you
he managed to restrain him somehow
clink I am not sure you'll be able to
stop him
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you must have been scored
huh
how is the master sword
[Music]
you're telling me
that link is safe
[Music]
you traveled through time to find me and
recover your strength
[Music]
Zelda
I believe there is a reason you were
sent to us
to mean something
[Music]
I know why I am here
something only I can do
we will finally stop him
to become an immortal dragon is to lose
oneself
I'll be forever changed
[Music]
link
you must find me
[Music]
you're saying that sword traveled
through time the same way you did
yes but more important ly in my original
time
The Demon King
was vulnerable to even the smallest
piece of this sword
even someone like him has
vulnerabilities
hmm
then what exactly are you suggesting we
do with the sword
time
the master sword is able to absorb
sacred power
it can heal itself and even grow
stronger
curious if we were able to empower it in
that way it could be the key to
defeating the Demon King
but it could take centuries for that
sword to grow strong enough the power
that Demon King wields
I do not see how this can be done it
would be impossible for you to provide
it with sacred power for so long
think of one way
I can do it I have to I've told you that
act is forbidden for a very good reason
it would mean throwing yourself away
[Music]
oh
you
won't be able to change back
[Music]
the moment I had the sword
I knew what to do
I knew this was why I came to this era
I
I want to restore the master sword and
deliver it to link
foreign
[Music]
you really have made up your mind
very well then as his own eye I bear my
share of blame for these events
so I too will devote myself to this goal
and to this hero of yours
for The Swordsman link I will do
everything I can
even if my body should perish I will
still be with you in spirit
[Music]
was that the sword that seals the
darkness
the blade that shatters so easily
against my power cannot save you from me
the sword will continue to gain strength
if bathed in sacred power
the stronger that power the more
powerful the sword becomes after all you
possess more than power over time
you have a sacred power
[Music]
power to swallow a secret stone is to
become an immortal Dragon one blessed
with eternal life
[Music]
I'm counting on you
leak I will restore the master sword for
you
I will care for it until the time comes
I will pour my sacred power into it
it will be the weapon that defeats the
Demon King
to become an immortal dragon is to lose
oneself
all right
you
[Music]
know
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
link
[Music]
the master sword your sword
she's the key to destroying the Demon
King
her before
long Slumber will heal these Grievous
wounds
and when you two next face The Demon
King
[Music]
you will have my strength to help you
through her
blink
you are our final hope
I pray
this sword reaches you in the future
foreign